This is the last project of the course. We'll be
putting together everything you've learned
so far. Affordances, signifiers, conceptual
model, system image, discoverablity, and feedback. For many of you,
this will be the first time you've thought about an
interface from the design side. You just use it. And
for others, perhaps you'll be thinking about stuff in new
ways. In any case, this is the capstone project for
the course, and we want you to bring it all together.
And you'll be amazed at what you create and learn in the process.
As we do this project, we'll also practice a few new key design methods
that will help you create new ideas,
faster prototypes and get feedback from users.
But don't worry about that now, you'll be doing it before you know it.